mr gentlemen forbid it man in
rome monday november 16 at the stadium will
stand should they should one piece on
the fragile diane all mark of 6 10th
anniversary
f since said jerome we live like to
see two presidents of parliaments ndinga
society all ten services
we  go see 18the not simply be bat
eyelashes bridge and all have suffered from bugs
bunny of view hardly twenty
inhabitants doping ama new chapter and
distrisoft nude tunisian sauce covadis
europe lagging behind spinali flavors
also enters a catch a straw
fascist diet  to be Jewish wants to play
will be the date faso here august unite all
pic willy depend on manifesto fruits
in all six grids in web and
italian mango within this movement in
fordism watine ten protesters and ten
new chapter spinaliens 3 6 10 said
clint d'  acn second and a half become
too many seniors presidency of the stops games
to day light in edreams stat the boat
was already leader dave watts 6.17 in
shots unexpected goal face
what is another in gouache he
gives his approval to  the breakage a good to be
brought espinal has too undergone
ambrosi troubles and where you have been to day
no time to be fine 10 1 cellar of vision
on date remake giving a mighty
ducks randy savage beauty i made
president maintains after the  anthem
colleagues and a tackle a dj steve hunt
or wild turkey and run a funny
and shaving woman globalized where terrorist
thumbs circular migration technology
officer head of the bad can do in
a hall european taxes tiff kraft
or throwing drag i took him
offended  the istia luge or in austria
rich china if with suntech joseph a
neil source of this match hurts the scholars
as it takes a league 1 gordon august
instead of six big a tower with michel
houdebine not in fed had a young
clown girl from morocco  neither citrus or
2014 integrating standards songs
very work music not europa daphnis
midi to europe in ussel versailles a
song mood until active in this
proactive misfortune of a play my friend
frank van oers exact timing at august 21
marne  wohlen for aaron arbitrations
that sprinkle bass daphnis guys a
period valve fund a
political party or a coach jean paul ii a
bright falls
bricks business site
works a non stop discount and go via
marne va et muzzle par  example
wenzhou europe quo vadis europe 1
winston europa sports anthems
is heinrich canberra usain bolt
dayron that's it
moody's underlines bernard i'm regaled
drummer suffice to steal them or don't
land newcomers
indifferent cows home india ovt
biblical says it  zoom already in gabon we
do it justice to a meat and rice kr
he raised dass die stimme in china
according to europe 1 often belong to the
farm found in the rope clothes of a
class when we saw the golden five
of eastman europe  in cannes will not see
women are not or houses of
human abbas to be all about us gibson
bows and arrows greceanii abbas lauzon
special fair of the navas jury at gicam
hartling tobacco with 10 waida to talent
and the league itself  logic red
robin outside europe came that we
meet info b110 national
mamatou serious race given that auspices of the
financial program a restitution
Thursday mouly the lunar star fault for
its survival at the automaton a breakthrough on this
match between caen and abbas  logic at t
or buyers and directs just like adrian
tsouli nord pays d'auge to the bathroom
we the common rail percent of the
muscles steinman mandji like the winds
of the browns robache of a line of
sales especially christophe to intervene at
all  what alan europe
das problem blues
i am in the name of the world and bob evans will go to
wangen live from a telescope
living in the sound of fun ah well if we
delete google news that since they re
calibration consent to denver in front of the
grizzlies  civil servants and campsites
he is a president of space for the
jean reuilles commission of falling for
lashes insight
he made a funny villain in this clash in
a reserve at the palacium one side and at
the asthmatic philosopher you turn who
land dresses at  soukouna of mr
you have europa league 5 hurtig april 10 to 12
eur 10 then at the stand make a
form of opening the vice for i had to
do china vig little cabbage kung fu is
obviously it takes a scenario 19 years
from a garage of  same as a game like
nist launched marine finish drinking under
steam commissions to see the movie
chennai ind breach lugs but joseph
imagine going to a form of art and
design not degenerate firms like changing
a 1st age scenarios  before strong
areas of abject political habitat
halsted commission in that
dignified atmosphere under the gun or in that
virtual engine room or a wave to the
soul that line a deep sense of the
yard of the commissions
ross ford flex gracia fruit since
said free trail collateral
initiatives projects to strong
focus our articles indignant that
grounds and difficult matches
a troop stand in and out and a face
to the national by the world bank to
offer extensive example pressed
verticals mission to regulate round these
eastman shales between bruce bochy
canadian brands by abruzzo the
bashing
after the ounce and treat saying
commission is at all levels a
drop valves old doctor brews bachy
10 developed a machine of earth
10 national jason with zoom vadamar
alundra nagui  first of all that a church
it will come from a subtle where we
positive in gaza the strain 2012 of the world
isa journal filled had to name jean
marc déry thanh binh marc guillou of
capital there is a 9am to 12pm turn to
a case comes everything  twisted will do that
we will opt for jean is someone
from the north of nantes is equal to 12 euros
peugeot neo-nazi blood stone age of
zombies neymar would be a cut scenario
france esteem from the south has he started
politics bonus nor commission jim jean
claude binet marc valley  guardian morning
around 10 calves slips me 10 in 6 hours
qanbar the wolf or funny the manual zoom
the jurist to this challenge of the european union
and this mr hassan omer to become a group
brian euro zone paris is getting smart
you're going badly you dress there  brand
or 2 euros college jeans I had
man show eaters under said steam who
will destroy the role of fishing at the level
of commissions on a machine and off
line and marc féral du sp2 strict
tagging of a guide s in writing
andré of his ships  mistral goal that
european juniors imagine tempo
farhangian valves crash of 0.9 to liguori
lynton v d'havas style nord which vegetates to
a dick rift
in another style of jean dreuil
different like a volley she is in
fact the fruit of sea turtles  neighbor
of other ice cream scales admitted to the
eich clinic in arthabaska from the multaq
start up is below refuses to live
for hours just a rise towards that was
shattered in saint-jean-de-losne only two
designs roughly it  is false rhythm and
spirit
jeuland said to martine rame third
formation of terrorism which will
mean that I refused asylum just emanates regine
a gt of muscat not tilted sesame
the kids around 10hoo of yen be fun
in the bar with  scania en like that of the
system like holy just go with it in
finland at the center to
geostrategic politics because of a back
to europe in gold ge servette inflicted
a thing that created so much
mansion sage bachelot you have europe made say
to me  say a frequent woman
throwing herself from the g6 offers fatigue lighthouse autonomy
by a farandole x ypsilon
this bottle of kenji kanna rifle
in a white backpack with that of brother
kakou 10,061 old brathwaite to remove
today in clermont 2 euros  by
size is going to be a very vast
a sad and you have to throw a lounge and
a barrage talent a woman would be a
ton of the arm tibane brashin of the jsp is
in prison now daphnis we are going to be
an obstacle and great 19 round avant
garde if
he  there are nine exclusions his age can
be included on screen and deeds
aim at folgensbourg anigo if we
operate this gymnasium valves different
machines in court in bath where he dies
david movement
integration conditions 6.10 at ogc nice if  we're going to
make you guide europe and gf org go face
the hands of the farc
fausta lhdaa pioneer jitian says
happy
because first we give back some
furniture from the crac which uses in blood francis
that one of the major burn victims his hymn to scrap
metal mesut ozil  barrage of
green and yellow massenet
such an approach I stay but without
having a scenario we mafia
national security disc in principle wenger
hopes to make belgian for fibering
hindenburg omen java once said
political or occurrence of 10 gate
1 is in  europe and I have done everything about
terrorism this crossroads it is worth the nature
of the maghreb with alstom
a party to buy until tuesday for
ben article dating books it's a
big go-slow around 2 a.m. manipulation
of a foundry the buyers want
advance or attentive and weary koné ten
young people earn too much I gave you a
250 da Feb gold in this teaser Sunday
dated June 23
rise up for music is she looking for I was
reading president script was like
appetizers the best
suppliers and  strauss a cassock but
redemption of a que monza this brief if
we at the crazy stunts times of india
finalist in linz leadership hyphen
i just have a hot climate and moussa
clean avatar
we need to be equal
narayan girl cloud in europe  and I
must cap
this dubbing I like factory is going to be
einstein ig bas trig europass one of the
new browser
ladies and gentlemen deputies all
these perspectives all that ski stick
all these theoretically possible projects
are choices available to us I  am
not going to tell you today
which of them has my
absolute preference, while having challenged the idea
that the European Union should be reduced
to the status of free
trade areas, which is not my concept  and
what does not correspond to the ambitions
of europe
I am not going to tell you my
absolute preference today because we make annuities
it is not up to me alone I regret it
nor to the commission to make its choices
how to say a splendid sun I
did not want to present the
final views of the commission
I did not think then that it had become
fashionable by executive potash the floor
will be in your parliament in
national parliaments in government in
civil society in short  to citizens contrary to what was
once the rule the commission
does not prescribe does not say no strip to
it wants to be listened to before
deciding definitively diktat but
listening does not correspond to my
temperament I am not  a dictator
but i like to say things as i
see them i would like to announce the color
my conception of the european union
today and i measure the disappointment of
those who would have liked me to announce the
color today  but we
prefer to listen before saying to those
who would like the
commission to say what it should
be to you before the debate I would say that we must not
confuse leadership and diktat
contrary to what has been done so
far
we want to  first listen before
we speak this can lead
from what I have been able to read to
major disappointments but it is a
method that does honor to democracy
not only representative towards
democracy as a whole talking about institutions for the
revision of  treaties of
institutional procedures debate which agitates those
who are installed in the comfort of the
bubble prayssas the oise that it will be necessary that at
all costs we all leave together
does not interest me for the moment
besides such a speech
does not  would be interested in citizens you
who hold meetings throughout the country
have you ever been asked a
question about the balance of powers
between the council the commission and the
parliament never that's never
I've never had a question  such a question so it's
a typically Brussels debate that apart from
those who are settled in the
comfort of the Brussels bubble
does not interest anyone
so we should not lead this
debate I am sure the day will come
when the treaties will have to be  adapted a
collective will but on the fly
collective will to put this
collective will does not exist today to be
able to give substance to this will collective cry
we need a real debate an
honest debate on europe is sure it is that
citizens expectations of the european union
this virtuous conversation must not
take place only in rome or only
on many occasions the summit is on
the occasion of the many many
debates right here it must take place
in the cities and the  regions all over
europe
it is with you ladies and gentlemen
deputies and with the member states
that we will hold a series of debates
on the future of europe
every voice but tiny even barely
audible must be heard the citizens will tell
us what  that they expect from
the European union it undoubtedly expressing
their doubts our questions
but also their hopes
for us to answer them the reading the
reading of the white paper which I
invite you to read
including its introduction and the
changes the arguments for  and against
will help us to frohmuhl and the right
answers
over the next few months the
commission will make new
contributions to this broad debate with a
series of reflection papers and
more specific proposals relating to
the major issues in tomorrow will be done
we present our ideas  I
strengthen the social dimension of
bars, which are essential in my eyes and to which
I pay all my attention,
finally what has produced applause
when we talk about social Europe do
not make the majority in this room
shame on you because the
social Europe and a main challenge for the
decades to come
we will present our views on
the deepening of
economic and monetary union and in particular on
the mechanisms which will improve the very
necessary coordination of economic policies
we will present our views on the
control  globalization and we
present our thoughts on the future
of defense in europe and the future of
european union defense finances
it is obvious that european states
will have to increase their military budget
but stability but planetary  is not
only a function of the size of
military budgets
global global international stability is also a function of the
size of development aid budgets
and funding for the
fight against climate change
reducing development aid budgets
calling into question the commitments that
were ours and those of others in
terms of climate change, I am
talking about kop 21, will seriously harm
full stability the european union
must carry and must continue to carry
these massages stability is
not only  the sphere of
armies is also the sphere of those who
want to help enable those who
are behind to join those who
are ahead stability is
military spending but not
exclusively military spending
it is also the  development aid and
the fight against climate change,
ladies and gentlemen, you have already addressed
all these issues and we
look forward to the idea of
continuing to work with us and in
particular with the rapporteurs, who have
seen their reports
recently adopted.  make an appointment with
you in september
in september during the state
of the union speech where i will further develop
his ideas casavant but after having
listened to each other
i would like the concert at the pnd in
december his orientations for a
process which will reach its peak during
the European elections in 2019
in 2019 we have an appointment with
European universal suffrage
it will be an appointment first
of explanation explanation between the
political forces, that is to say between the
political families who will have to say
how they see Europe in the year 20 25
and beyond
and I would like the
democratic process started in 2014 to see
its extension
I mean by this that in 2009 the
European parties should present
heads of  lists of
requirements that we will have to
respect for
European democracy to work and remain credible
we cannot denounce in 2019 the
achievements that we seem to have
accomplished in 2014
I also give friendly greetings to the
candidates who have not  I was not lucky that
I was able to have
Mr. Verhofstadt
you are distinguished by exuberant optimism
yes the main thing is to participate
always participate by surveys
always European citizens thirsty to be
able to decide who will be the next
President of the European Commission
citizens must be able to make their
choice through government offices
I will not be a candidate for a second
term as I said from
day one but I will not deprive you thank you
I intended never to
disappoint the far right I  I succeeded I
will not be a candidate for a second
term
but believe me I am neither tired nor
out of ideas on the contrary and you
will see Mr. President Europe
has risen from the Second
World War to actually achieve
the  'impossible to put an end to this
eternal tragedy European tragedy
which in fact forced us the peoples the
leader to choose between war
and peace in the world today
more than 40 wars and
military conflicts are raging but not in this
is not happening  takes place on European soil
proper seen from further away seen
from other continents europe
continues to remain a magnificent thing
having brought together an entire continent having put
an end to this disastrous post-
war writing which wanted europe  forever
from 70 years of the bloc he admits to creating a
new space of stability, prosperity and equality the admiration of the whole world
very often I have the impression that
others are coming to us and that we ourselves are
happening  to hate us, but this
Europe the one I am describing is neither a
given nor an evidence Europe has
always been
remains today and forever a
deliberate choice that must be defended
against all odds against the sister
of what  does not want to understand the
course of history and the choices
we make now today tomorrow
two years from
now until 2025 must take into account their
implication not only for us but
above all for the generations to come
because we  we will be judged not on
what has been bequeathed to us but on what
we leave as a legacy
we citizens often tell us that we
have to do things differently
yes we are ready for it but we must
not want to change everything
we should try to
understand better  the constraints and the france
a correct application of the principle of
subsidiarity which must not become
an ersatz for solidarity which must
remain the guiding principle of
all our European and national actions
very often by listening to those who
act as the president's lawyer  I have
the impression that he does not want to
talk about solidarity
he prefers to talk about subsidiarity it
is a question of clearly understanding the
exact meaning of the concept of
subsidiarity
we have not taken measures have the
right to be  how to say patriots
against others the patriotism of the 21st
century is declined in two dimensions
a happy patriotism accepted and
accepted and inside the solidarity
which the extension of happy patriotism
outwards there are
values ​​which must continue  to
unite us peace democracy solidarity
the rule of law that will be the rule
that underlies our living together very
often threatened the dignity and equality
of all states were all
human beings freedom of the press
look at what is happening in turkey where
german journalists are imprisoned for no reason because they
dared to say what had to be said the
values ​​yes which includes the refusal of the
rejection of the other of those who are
different from us  but who is no
less noble than ourselves, we
cannot accept that the voices of
those who defend values ​​which I
would like to see universal be
drowned out by the din of
nationalist slogans which make patriotism
a soul against others  patriotism is
no longer patriotism
when it is directed against others
europe must remain a
positive global force our society our
european societies are built on
openness
we should be more proud of it
others prefer to close in  on
themselves and turn their gaze
inwards
navel-gazing is making
agonizing progress across the planet
but such an attitude such a
navel-gazing attitude is neither of any other
nature nor moreover in our interest
democracy whole democracy is
a European product and we will
defend it by all and with all our
strength
so let's have the courage the patience the
determination which are necessary either
or long journeys and with great
ambitions
europe continues to be a great
ambition
an ambition that has behind  her and
ahead of her a long journey today we have
the choice between many
paths
some more pernicious than others others
more promising for the future than
others whatever the game the
president the choice we will make the
destiny of europe at 27 is in our
hands in our hands yes but it is
first and foremost a matter of the
heart and a matter of values ​​of
values ​​which give its true
dimension to the european reason of state
I am not  not quoting a
european poem i am describing a
continental necessity thanks for having me and cutter
[applause]